okay what up guys this is a video for
the subscribers that have donated um and
you want to know where your money is
going as you guys know i don't even keep
money right now on the channel i
literally just put all the money
reinvest it back into the channel
and i want to tell you guys where the
money is going so
and what we're saving for next okay
so recently
um let me tell you i added these foam
panels to the wall
now
i don't know it's like
i don't know 20 30ish foam panels is 100
bucks
reason it's 100 bucks is these are like
thicker and they're like more absorbent
um i just noticed a big difference when
i bought the like higher quality ones
you can see that versus that it's like a
little thinner
then over here
sorry it's a little bit of a mess to
them
i just added on four new mics
and a new road caster pro so now we
don't have to have guest share mics
anymore
um i also bought headphones but right
now i can only get
four so
um i'd like to get eight and that way
like i think the guests will better
remember to like stay closer to the
the
mics
other thing i got
is
new table here so before we had that
glass table i'm using it like as a desk
now
and over here we're going to be doing
more
like sit-down interviews with people
sorry my washer's over there it can be
loud
and so like basically i'll be sitting
behind the camera or on the couch
someone sits there someone sits there
and we put
a camera like here
here ish
and film it so now what do we need next
to get the complete setup so we're
saving for
four more pairs of headphones i want to
buy a chair to put there
and
a second and a third camera so we can
get different angles here
um yeah so that's what we're doing with
the money right now
all donations um
can be sent to so that's what we're
doing with the money right now all
donations can be sent to my paypal which
is hannahpurldavis gmail.com it's a
weird name it's under a hap system it's
because i can't get it to change back i
don't know why it's like an old job i
had i
drives me crazy cash at pearly things
um venmo just underscore pearly things
and yeah so
i just want you guys to see exactly what
i'm doing with your money shout out to
zentiance my biggest donor so far
appreciate you
sir
none of this these updates would have
been possible without the donations or
any of the other donations everybody has
sent so appreciate you guys
um let me know what color the next chair
should be in the studio